son sobre violaciones de los derechos
humanos en chile ellos formaron parte de
esta delegación pero primero y antes que
todo un caluroso saludo a todos ustedes
allá del otro lado del micrófono y de la
pantalla de las cámaras y bueno deseamos
que este programa de hoy sea de su total
agrado muchísimas gracias por su
agradable compañía pero antes antes de
entrar de lleno con nuestros invitados y
de entrar de lleno con este castor
cibernético
no sé si hay algo insólito por ahí me ha
causado a mí me encantan las efemérides
son interesantes esta vez poco en
realidad lo que hago es buscar la semana
la semana pasada hasta el día de este
fin de semana que es donde sale el
programa en internet mientras tanto les
cuento que el día 10 de febrero fue el
día mundial de las legumbres
que esta buena ensalada
la cooperativa donde los compro a cada
dos semanas el 11 el día internacional
de la mujer y la niña en la ciencia
eso es un día internacional tampoco lo
conocíamos el 11 también es el día
internacional de la epilepsia la jornada
mundial del enfermo y el día
internacional del día del internet
seguro no existe
el 12 el día mundial contra el uso del
niño soldado es el 13 es el día mundial
de la radio estuvo festejando las radios
asociadas por radio rumanía
internacional y radio praga internet
exacto el 13 también fue el día mundial
en realidad me parece muy gracioso pues
el día mundial del soltero que es el día
de san valentín el 13 le puso el día
mundial del soltero y por el san
valentín en nos toca bien el corazón
bien el profundo en el corazón también
es el día mundial de la cardiopatía
congénita
de corazón
esto es una relación lógica de esos días
internacionales así que esa es la
efemérides de días internacionales no
vamos a meter en detalle quién nació que
murió el 90 pero veremos los días
internaciones de sobre todo algo que
fantástico luis laborda tú nos hablas de
iphone y de moneda no si yo estoy
hablábamos precisamente de la necesidad
o el deseo que tiene mucha gente unos
incluye a veces en eso también de
cambiar su teléfono móvil este aparato
que todos disponemos últimamente la
mayoría
del costo que tienen estos teléfonos y
de lo caro que muchas veces éste el
momento no quiere tiene que renovarlos y
yo te comentaba el otro día precisamente
de que tengo ganas de cambiarlo por uno
que tenga una pantalla un poco más
grande para poder ver vídeos más
cómodamente etcétera bueno que aguanta
las ganas me aguanto las ganas pues
sobre todo mi bolsillo
aguantarlo me da otro día de día me
olvidarás de esa hora la información
aquí prosigue el caso de un estudiante
ex estudiante aquí en canadá que
comentaba el caso de un ex compañero de
estudios en el territorio canadiense que
cuando llegó el momento de renovar su
teléfono en este caso es pues
específicamente un iphone
fue acumulando moneda sobre moneda a lo
largo de un año y después de un año de
juntar moneditas por monedita tuvo el
dinero suficiente para comprarse un
iphone teléfono que yo uso desde hace
muchos años pero que vengo diciendo
desde hace ya tiempo que se ha puesto en
caprichosa si digamos en irracionalmente
caro todo es uno de los teléfonos más
vendidos es comprensible de historia
mientras más caros más vendidos o por lo
menos digamos sigue ahí a cabeza a
cabeza con la que es uno de los modelos
más caros en este momento pues está
horrible creo que es de 2.500 dólares y
hay muchísima gente que encuentra razón
suficiente pero no solamente encuentra
la razón encuentra los billetes
suficientes para comprarse 12 mil 500
dólares un precio que ella me parece
fuera de toda racionalidad así que bueno
este este personaje el cual tú hablas
que ahorro moneda por moneda me imagino
que era moneda de dónde va
alcanza que ahorrar monedas sobre
monedas a lo largo de un año para
comprar un teléfono móvil
la experiencia me hubiese parecido aún
más dolorosa pero tú sabes el cuñado mío
solía antes vaciarse el bolsillo de
todas las monedas que tenía y los echaba
en un recipiente todos los días hacía
eso y al final del año pues con eso se
podía comprar un tiquete de avión para
irse de vacaciones en verano igual hay
que tener ahora en la época del paypass
justamente de las cosas no usamos las
tarjetas casi casi no hay dinero en
efectivo
dando vueltas imagínense yo que tengo un
billete cada tres meses más o menos la
mano de chocolate claro
y hablando de aguantarse la cara de él
me hace pensar en un chiste de un amigo
mío que decía tengo unas ganas de
trabajar pero me las aguas
lo mío es un poco más bueno ni más ni
menos cómico pero es esta historia que
muy probablemente ustedes oyeron en
radio canadá esto sucedió en gris acné
en la región sangre de una pareja que
bueno analizó su mercado como siempre lo
hacía todas las semanas y entre las
verduras que habían comprado compraron
pimientos verdes no y la sorpresa de la
señora fue grande cuando al cortar el
pimiento se dio cuenta que estaba así
rico proteínas agregadas porque había
una ranita había una ranita viva
ahí está la ranita y la herramienta pues
- menos mal que encontró la la ranita y
no media ranita
porque hubiera sido bastante estrés y si
hubiera sido cruel para la pobre señora
de haber asesinado pero sabes que que el
final de la ranita fue trágico de todas
formas porque llamaron al ministerio de
agricultura de quebec para informarles
no de esto porque ellos son los que se
encargan también de toda la seguridad de
las cosas que se importan alimentos
verduras y todo esto y la mataron a la
gringa halal a la ranita para analizarla
para ver si no había ningún
problema eventual no de transición de
alguna enfermedad etcétera
ordenada más no la tuvieron que abrir
por el pobre ron el pobre ranita esto
hacia eso me pareció curioso y muy
insólito que vaya si tienes una sorpresa
cuando bajas
ahora encontrarse una ranita y no yo el
año pasado encontraron cucarachas dentro
de una de esas ensaladas que vienen
cerradas la sirvieron así presionar el
vinagre y estaba ocupará esas redes está
recibiendo el vinagre así o sea hay que
tener mucho cuidado porque se
empaquetadas por ahí no sé si pasa todos
los controles de calidad entonces habría
que mirar con mucha atención
bueno pues seamos cuidadosos en lo que
respecta a las cucarachas y bueno ahora
sí regresamos con nuestros invitados de
hoy marie christine doran y ricardo
peñafiel que como decíamos al principio
formaron parte de una delegación
canadiense de observación sobre
violaciones de derechos humanos en chile
una delegación formada por diversas por
personas de diversas especializaciones
campos de intervención disputa
etcétera y bueno ustedes regresaron hace
poco en qué momento se llevó a cabo esta
esta misión
marie christine bueno la misión se llevó
a cabo del 18 al 27 de enero y se
terminó con una conferencia de prensa en
santiago donde fue un éxito
absolutamente habéis ha vaya a ser 8
porque hasta llegó se tienen a santiago
a escucharla 18 medios de comunicación
en chile y nosotros lo interpretamos
como que en chile la verdad es que
estaban mirando mucho hacia canadá que
es un país con el cual chile tiene
muchos lazos comerciales y culturales
etcétera y fue muy importante la
presencia de canadienses en ese momento
para decir bueno nosotros estamos aquí
en solidaridad con la sociedad chilena
que se está movilizando desde ya hace
tres meses casi para reclamar una
asamblea constituyente plena y varias
cosas terminar con las desigualdades de
ese país que es uno de los más
desiguales de américa latina cuántas
personas formaban parte de esta
delegación
29 y la especificidad de la delegación
es que éramos cinco académicos tres
sindicalistas yo tenían los dos sobreros
y dos diputados en las tres principales
centrales un diputado de provincial otro
del federal entonces era bastante
interesante esta composición que también
nos permitía la diferencia de otras
otros informes que han sido hechos por
organizaciones especializadas en
derechos humanos nosotros teníamos una
concepción más general de los derechos
humanos como algo que son integrales y
solidarios e indivisibles entonces el
derecho laboral el derecho también a la
manifestación más allá de la
manifestación derechos sociales y
justamente el análisis que hacemos es
también los orígenes a partir de la
dictadura y también se dice no son 30
pesos son 30 años son 30 años del
neoliberalismo
y justamente con una pseudodemocracia
que mantuvo la constitución pinochetista
de 1980 y esa constitución está hecha
contra los derechos sociales a la salud
la educación el alojamiento y todo eso
porque es una constitución neoliberal
que quita la concepción republicana en
la cual se reconocía el derecho los
derechos sociales entonces esos derechos
sociales que han sido vulnerados durante
todos estos años son los que explican el
estallido social y también la impunidad
hace que las fuerzas del orden
se comporten como extremadamente
represivas aquí y en qué consistió el
trabajo como tal mire nosotros estuvimos
haciendo más de 65 horas de entrevista
digamos durante 7 días entonces fueron
días muy llenos con vimos a más 52
organizaciones entre las cuales hay una
gran variedad por ejemplo estaban bueno
el colegio de médicos de chile el
colegio periodistas que también son
agredidos
al intentar de dar algún tipo de ayuda a
la población civil que está en las
calles hay médicos que tienen hay
balines o sea tienen heridas muy graves
y lamentablemente carabineros de chile
apunta hacia los ojos de periodistas y
médicos
y llegar a los medios muchas personas
que habían perdido
[Música]
227 personas con lesiones oculares de
las cuales más de 30 han perdido un ojo
y dos personas dos ojos y eso incluye un
periodista de meganoticias que es un
canal bien centrista
digamos y hielera y va bien identificado
y perdió el ojo entonces ese es bueno
entre las personas que conocimos fueron
esas asociaciones muy importantes como
portavoces también del movimiento del
movimiento organizaciones sindicales
feministas que son en este momento muy
muy fuertes y muy representativas de un
anhelo de la sociedad chilena de
terminar con todas las violencias es el
lema de la fe de las feministas
actualmente terminemos con todas
violencias en contra de cualquier
persona no solamente bueno contra las
mujeres todavía hay muchas pero además
ellas proponen como un cambio total de
cultura y obviamente oponiéndose a la
represión entonces conocimos pudimos
hablar con víctimas 99 personas que nos
dieron su testimonio y lo cual como
conclusión tenemos muy claro de que la
represión en chile sigue los protocolos
de carabineros que ellos mismos se han
dado no se aplican y el gobierno chileno
lo que más nos preocupa a nosotros es
que en este momento nosotros hablamos
con la subsecretaría de derechos humanos
del ministerio de justicia y ellos no
reconocen violaciones de derechos
humanos hasta que esas violaciones hayan
sido juzgadas en un tribunal lo cual
obviamente se demora mucho tiempo
entonces el juego en este momento de
parte del gobierno chileno es decir
bueno hay dos hay dos violaciones
reconocidas porque hay dos casos que
fueron juzgados pero nada más el resto
no sabemos qué pasa
tremendamente absurdo frente a las y
hace falta que este proceso para que con
pie comiencen estos juicios para que
realmente se tome el que no se dé cuenta
efectivamente qué es lo que pasa y que
se tomen medidas para que esto siga
pasando bueno lamentablemente en chile
mientras no le duele el bolsillo a la
burguesía la oligarquía está va a seguir
lamentablemente lo que permite estas
violaciones sistemáticas de los derechos
y masivas de los derechos humanos es un
sistema global en el sentido que los
jueces van a hay 2.000 personas
actualmente con cárcel preventiva por
delitos menores así por pegarle a romper
un estar rompiendo un entorno y qué
eso ni siquiera tiene cárcel como pena
máxima que puedes tener por eso el
vandalismo no nos lleva a cárcel y sin
embargo la persona un profesor estuvo en
cárcel durante 30 días hasta que
lograron sacar porque porque lo ponían
bajo causas de terrorismo pero
en los jueces colaboran lamentablemente
no todos pero colaboran con este tipo de
también prejuicio entonces se permiten
comentarios diciéndole a la gente a los
jóvenes que no tenían por qué protestar
si no protestaran no tendrían los
problemas que están que están
denunciando entonces esta justicia que
además aplica las leyes nacionales que
están en contradicción con convenciones
internacionales firmadas por chile en
teoría esas convenciones internacionales
fueron integradas sin embargo los jueces
se interpretan la ley chilena
además hay leyes hay decretos porque la
ley chilena permite la manifestación la
constitución aún siendo pinochetista
salvo que un decreto del 83 de estipula
tan tan tal cosa entonces están
utilizando leyes de la dictadura
decretos de la dictadura para aplicar
esa represión entonces ahí están los
jueces que colaboran y no sólo eso todo
el sistema también la administración en
los dos hospitales que le dicen
le dan como orden administrativa a los
médicos de las enfermeras no registrar
el origen de las heridas porque porque
las cifras son realmente dan miedo pero
esas cifras son ni siquiera un tercio de
lo que está ocurriendo porque no se está
registrando hay gente que es desaparecía
no como antes que se desvanecía para
siempre pero que van a ser golpeados en
los autos patrullas dejados en el borde
y nunca se registró el arresto y hay
gente que ha muerto así entonces igual
se encontró press encontró el cuerpo y
así los vídeos son y lucientes nada uno
ve en las redes sociales la gente está
haciendo un trabajo súper intenso yo
tengo muchos contactos chilenos y lo que
se ve es realmente la pena y la amargura
que ni siquiera eso porque digamos
estamos viviendo en la era de la imagen
del vídeo y ni siquiera eso ayuda a que
las autoridades digan está pasando o sea
se ningunea a lo que la gente hace
y se sigue aplicando mano dura y sin
tipo sin ningún tipo de restricción
cuando es evidente que lo que está
pasando no está bien y hay algún plan
digamos porque esto ustedes decían que
el origen es de la época desde la época
de pinochet
por qué tardó tanto en surgir este
descontento qué fue lo que pasó en chile
para que esto acontezca dores
ver después tu regresar con la muerte
las presiones que queremos el ser sobre
que nada porque lamentablemente
estábamos hablando de los teléfonos el
litio y los intereses mineros que nadie
se haya limitan la voluntad de canadá de
hacer presión pero ahora como por qué
tardó tanto en uno de nosotros maría
cristina escribió un libro sería tu
pregunta en el cual sitúa en el 2003 el
momento en que chile despertó o sea
despertó hace mucho tiempo es algo que
justamente este sistema político chileno
que es justamente en la política de los
acuerdos no los acuerdos sociales con
los actores sociales sino que acuerdos
entre partidos políticos para excluir
los sectores sociales manifestaciones y
movimientos sociales no dejaron de haber
desde el primer día de la posdictadura
al salvo que siempre reprimidos
menospreciados entonces lo que ocurrió
hoy en día es que hoy en día están
estallando todo uno de los puntos más
fuertes es no más
afp esos son los las pensiones privadas
ejemplo eso la cotización individual que
hace que la gente que se quedó en el
antiguo sistema
de antes de la dictadura recibe tres
veces más la pensión tres veces más y
quien se llevó esa plata fueron los
capitales privados que muchas veces le
pertenecen a los mismos diputados
entonces y esto está encima el sistema
no funcionó hoy en día está lleno de
todos los jubilados son muy pero muy
pobres reciben menos de 300 dólares al
mes con costos de la vida
iguales a los que hay aquí entonces
fenómeno de suicida es ese movimiento
llegó a convocar un millón de personas
hace un año en una manifestación otro
movimiento muy fuerte son las feministas
que al convocar una huelga general el 8
de marzo pasado hoy en día
va a volver a empezar las
manifestaciones que no se olviden que
son cotidianas la represión sigue porque
las manifestaciones siguen al cada día
hay por lo menos una manifestación por
ciudad para santiago presta todas las
ciudades no paran la gente de
manifestarse y bueno entonces el 8 de
marzo vuelve con todo porque sea
el verano es como el 8 de septiembre del
equivalente aquí internacional de las
mujeres y entonces el 8 y el 9 porque
los choca un domingo entonces el 9 una
huelga general
feminista pero trans seccionales e
intersección en el sentido de que
feministas que trabajan a nivel sindical
a nivel del medio ambiente a todos los
niveles es la articulación justamente de
una perspectiva
contra todas las violencias en todos los
aspectos
recordemos y eso es muy importante que
hubo un acuerdo entre los partidos en el
mes de noviembre para tener una asamblea
constituyente o sea un voto para decidir
el 26 de abril si la población chilena
quiere tener una asamblea constituyente
con 50 por ciento de partidos o
plenamente constituyente y ahora al
comienzo eso fue muy mal recibido por
parte de la población civil porque sé
que se acordó de que no habían no había
paridad de género en la asamblea tampoco
habían digamos puestos para pueblos
indígenas que fueran ya representativos
de su número entonces mucha gente
protestaba en contra de ese acuerdo pero
en este momento la verdad nosotros hemos
visto casi todas las organizaciones
están empujando para que se gane el voto
a la asamblea constituyente a favor de
la asamblea y en la asamblea plena y eso
nos vemos que hay un cambio y la verdad
la gente allá está muy preocupada de que
la represión sea aún más fuerte si es
posible
durante el mes de marzo porque lo que
vemos es que y es una de las
conclusiones de la delegación de las
naciones unidas también y de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos en
este momento el gobierno chileno está
apuntando a que la gente va a tener
tanto miedo va a tener terror de salir a
la calle por eso vemos violaciones por
parte de carabineros cosas que nos
explican no si no es para decir ustedes
no se metan a la calle y entonces la
apuesta es que la gente se calme y vaya
a su casa y vemos que eso no está
sucediendo al contrario exactamente y de
hecho se habla en chile de ese en un
marco de supuesta democracia y hablando
de terrorismo de estado justamente hubo
alguna interferencia por parte del
estado mientras ustedes estaban haciendo
su trabajo ya por qué no
con nosotros no hicieron nada sino
digamos con la subsecretaría de derechos
humanos mandaron a personas que fueron
muy amables pero que no eran los
delegados que esperábamos no digamos los
representantes y nos la embajada tampoco
nos recibió de canadá
entonces pero sabían que estaban muy
ocupados posiblemente pero la cosa es
que después de nosotros vino por una
segunda visita a la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos y ahí
sí el gobierno chileno dijo ustedes no
tienen por qué meterse en asuntos
internos y eso es muy grave es un
precedente porque pues eso también
demuestra que el chileno está dispuesto
a respetar las convenciones crean
nosotros no nos han dicho nada la línea
común entre chile y canadá es que chile
es un estado de derecho que en el cual
justamente canadá subrayó el hecho de
que chile permitía las comisiones
internacionales de entrar entonces ese
fue como un error
dentro de la línea argumentativa
retórica del gobierno chileno es decir
que ya basta de comisiones
internacionales que la injerencia pero
tampoco prosperó es a ese argumento la
línea que tienen es que justamente yo
son un estado derecho que transparente
que permiten
organismos internacionales de venir y
ver lo que está pasando esa parte es
verdad pero justamente cuando esta y que
ellos dicen se cumple la ley salvo que
si 38 casos sobre miles de querellas
sólo son procesados entonces la ley
había un artículo justamente decía así
demora no es justicia para dar vuelta
eso es la de justicia de muera pero
llega en este caso se demora tanto si
dentro de cinco años se establece que el
gobierno tenía responsabilidad en
violaciones de derechos humanos va a ser
muy tarde actualmente se están violando
sistemáticamente con complicidad del
sistema y entonces eso es un sistema de
derechos sí pero dentro del cual el
derecho está es disfuncional con sus
funciones de ahora yo quería ahondar en
eso y precisamente preguntarles cuál
creen ustedes que debería ser la
respuesta del gobierno canadiense a la
situación en chile porque tenemos que
recordar que la semana próxima hay aquí
en canadá una reunión del grupo de lima
en el cual el país va a aprovechar para
reiterar su preocupación por la
situación en venezuela
pero esa preocupación no es igual no es
equiparable a la que ha demostrado está
agua por la situación que se vive en
chile con la reiterada violación a los
derechos humanos que vienen ocurriendo
desde hace meses y con la cantidad de
gente como decía ricardo cardona cierto
el nombre de detenidos que ha habido no
solamente quienes o difiero con lo que
tú has dicho no se trata solamente de
faltas menores sino recordamos todos
porque lo han respetado incluso los
medios sociales de comunicación las
detenciones arbitrarias al tuntún como
se dice de gente que ha sido levantada
de la calle de caminar y aunque
estuviera cometiendo ningún tipo de
delito ni falta de nada que respuesta ha
dado o cuál debería dar a esta situación
bueno justamente nosotros primero que
todos queremos decir que estamos
trabajando con varias organizaciones de
la comunidad chilena aquí en canadá que
han sido muy activos y ellos han hecho
peticiones varias peticiones de hecho
hay una petición en este momento en el
parlamento por una diputada del npd
de vancouver para que el gobierno
canadiense sea muy claro en cuanto al
rechazo de esas violaciones a los
derechos humanos y que llame la atención
del gobierno
perdón del gobierno chileno en respetar
las convenciones internacionales porque
en este momento la respuesta ha sido del
gobierno canadiense bueno vemos con
digamos beneplácito el hecho de que
chile permita la entrada de las misiones
internacionales como dice y eso es
cierto que es bueno porque en venezuela
por ejemplo no se le permitió a la
comisión interamericana entrar de nuevo
bueno dicho sea de paso pero sin embargo
más allá de eso no hay ninguna
condenación y vemos que por ejemplo
pueblos indígenas y mujeres que son
prioridades supuestas del gobierno
canadiense están siendo vulneradas
atacadas sin ningún tipo de respuesta y
el gobierno canadiense nos ha dicho
desde la conferencia de prensa de la
semana pasada
estaban buscando una solución inclusiva
con el gobierno chileno lo cual no
quiere decir mucho entonces si la idea
es justamente y eso es muy importante la
comunidad chilena dice porque cuando se
trata de la comunidad venezolana en
canadá que obviamente está más opuesta
al gobierno actual de maduro si el
gobierno canadiense responde y nosotros
que la inmensa mayoría como el chile yo
no soy chilena pero ellos dicen nosotros
estamos opuestos a las violaciones de
derechos humanos en nuestro país y
nuestro gobierno no dice nada no
entienden están muy muy muy preocupados
con esa situación hay un peso dos
medidas antes de despedir a nuestros
invitados leonardo tenemos algún
comentario de oyentes uno uno solo y en
este caso es arrodeas char decía en
últimas que está pasando en chile que es
lo que se busca cuando esto
la pregunta si es con todo esto la
participación internacional la
canadiense o con todo esto lo que está
pasando socialmente acá así que fue mi
posición es que lo que está ocurriendo
en chile es una revolución justamente si
llego hasta el límite de lo tolerable de
este neoliberalismo brutal que fue
impuesto de forma militar y después que
fue mantenido de forma ideológica pero
también sumamente represiva la ley
antiterrorista que se le aplicó
sistemáticamente a los mapuches pueblos
indígenas del sur de chile todo tipo de
acción justamente a favor de en contra
del extractivismo y de la destrucción de
la naturaleza es reprimida con una
fuerza increíble y como dicen las
feministas todas las mujeres contra
todas las violencias es un front-end
frente que está en todas partes entonces
esa lucha contra todo tipo de
autoritarismo que existe en chile desde
hace 46 años eso va y por eso para mi
modo de ver es una revolución feminista
y el 8 de marzo y el 9 de marzo va a ser
muy fuerte
hay mucha gente que apuesta a la caída
del gobierno porque tiene 6% de apoyo el
sistema de partido tiene 3 por ciento de
apoyo entonces como un gobierno y un
sistema de partidos o instituciones que
no tienen ninguna legitimidad pretenden
seguir la única respuesta que dado el
gobierno ha sido leyes represivas que
van aún más o sea lo que era prohibido
antes ahora se va a volver ley pero eso
no es una solución entonces no se la
pregunta es que rivas y era de parte del
gobierno de parte de la cia de parte de
nosotros que estamos haciendo allá
nosotros respondimos al llamado del alto
comisionado de derechos humanos de las
naciones unidas que con ellos estamos
trabajando en chile nos encontramos con
ellos ellos han dicho que necesitan más
delegaciones que vayan para demostrar
que las violaciones siguen ocurriendo
entonces la gran preocupación de
naciones unidas y de la comisión
interamericana decir no está terminando
y eso también hace que no se solucionen
la cosa porque la gente está totalmente
desconcertada entre tantas
entonces igual yo supongo que el cambio
no tendría que ser estético digamos
poner otro partido sino un cambio de
raíz que realmente erradique todo lo que
viene hace 30 años normalmente como yo
sé que ustedes tienen otros compromisos
algo ustedes presentaron este informe
preliminar y cuál es la próxima etapa
bueno el informe va a salir de aquí un
par de semana hay una campaña también
con la comunidad chilena o los diversos
grupos que se organizaron al calor de
esta represión increíble que ha surgido
para hacer presión sobre el gobierno
canadiense es importantísimo que el
gobierno tenga alguna forma de que tenga
que pagar por lo que está haciendo no
puedes seguir impune esta situación y la
única el único amparo que tiene la
población chilena hoy en día es la
comunidad internacional que tiene que
hacer presión y no va a ser sólo canadá
pero que nada tiene gran importancia
también por una relación privilegiada la
mayoría de la inversión en la minería
viene de canadá y el problema también
porque dentro uno habla de
neoliberalismo y proyectos a que inicie
las ocurre privatización del agua
privatización de ríos las compañías
mineras están comprando todo el agua
para su extracción de minerales y dejas
sin agua la pobla
son cosas que ni ni siquiera se queda
corta la palabra neoliberalismo para
entender lo que se está viviendo en
chile así que una campaña a partir de
aquí son las próximas etapas
lo vamos a hacer entonces no sólo el
informe sino que acompañado con mucha
gente que y el senado chilenos la
oposición nos ha pedido que volvamos
como delegación internacional para
vigilar las elecciones en abril en abril
para la nueva constitución así que muy
bien ricardo peñafiel marie-christine
ground muchísimas gracias por haberse
desplazado hasta aquí hasta nuestros
estudios y muchísimas gracias por
ese sobrevuelo de la situación en chile
muchas gracias y bueno nosotros vamos a
continuar acá mi estimado y querido
leonardo con nuestra aplicación en una
aplicación que desde ya le pedimos a
todos ustedes por allá y a nuestros
invitados que la baja en que la trabajen
y la tengan en sus teléfonos para
mantenerse bien informados así es la
aplicación es la manera más fácil más
rápida y segura de poder
chequear los contenidos que produce
radio canal internacional en las cinco
lenguas en realidad aconsejamos a los
que hablan español bajar la española en
el español pues venga vale también
tienen la posibilidad de bajada desde
bajarlas en francés en inglés en árabe y
en chino para que esos que tenga no sólo
tenemos un oyente que por lo menos tres
aplicaciones tiene de todas estas así
que la recomendación es bajar la pueden
ver este programa que estamos haciendo
en el sector de vídeos nuestros vídeos
sale el programa en el momento en vivo y
en directo así que la recomendación es
bajar la aplicación pueden ir a nuestra
página internet a la derecha arriba
tienen un link en la publicidad de la
aplicación para ir a las dos tiendas
oficiales más grandes para los teléfonos
más caros y los no tan caros
la aplicación de las dos tiendas cuando
lo deseen a partir de nuestra página o
bien yendo a estas tiendas de apple
de android directamente y poniendo radio
canadá internacional en español bueno
pues ya si van a tener esta aplicación
en sus teléfonos celulares y bueno con
un solo clic pues van a tener acceso a
toda la información que nosotros
producimos aquí en radio canadá
internacional algún comentario por ahí
louis sí señor aquí tengo un mensaje que
nos envía javier gonzález nungaray sobre
el tema montreal prohibir a toda la
bolsa de plástico en su territorio un
tema que publicamos recientemente dice
javier gonzález nunca hará y creo que
estas determinaciones de las autoridades
de diferentes ciudades en este caso
montreal son buenos proyectos que si se
realizan vamos a mejorar la calidad de
vida de los ciudadanos en general es el
mensaje de javier si aquí con un poquito
de presbicia tema el summum de montreal
hospital que nació con la ciudad
martha ovalle nos dice tuvo una urgencia
de septiembre del 2019 en su hospital y
quedarán de enviarme una factura y la
historia clínica lo cual no ha pasado y
nos piden nosotros
podemos interceder para buscar la
factura y le decimos a marta que
lamentablemente nos encantaría poder
ayudarle pero tiene que hablar
directamente con las autoridades de
pertinentes del hospital para poder
lograr hacerse de esa factura y antes de
pasar a nuestros temas que vamos a
sugerirles a nuestros oyentes que pueden
ir a ver si tienen la aplicación van a
ir directamente a nuestra aplicación
vamos a
quiero dar hoy en los controles técnicos
el crédito a leo boulanger a pierre lee
la pierde útil sin esas tres personas
pues este programa no estaría disponible
para todos ustedes y vamos ahora con los
temas que hemos tratado esta semana tú
leonardo tú nos hablas de un malware o
de un programa maligno no si es en
realidad la desmitificación de una
historia larga hace años que se viene
hablando justamente de que windows es
mucho más vulnerable a los virus que la
empresa de la manzana que macintosh en
este caso ha salido un estudio reciente
hace un par de semanas nada más donde
dice que en realidad no es tan así
después de años y años de campañas es
más se utilizó una campaña la pongo ahí
y después de 30 años vine a decírmelo
que en realidad no es tan seguro como
como antes
y en realidad el estudio habla
puntualmente de que cualquier
dispositivo conectado a internet es
vulnerable hoy en día no es necesario
que sea más que android windows en el
que sea es vulnerable porque digamos que
la tecnología con la que se recibe ahora
y con la que se ataca a estos
dispositivos es mucho más refinada que
la que se usaba hace 20 años atrás así
que bueno esto es como para contarles un
poco de qué se trata y la historia de
esta gran rivalidad entre mac
y windows también es cierto en la última
década los productos de la firma apple
se han hecho más populares y eso también
el de su precio a pesar de su precio sí
y eso también puso en la mira de la
atención de quienes generan este tipo de
programas de espionaje de infección
etcétera que antes no se preocupan
demasiado porque tenían un mercado muy
muy reducido esto también lo dice en el
artículo hablando puntualmente de lo que
pasaba hace un par de años atrás
una década atrás y lo que pasa ahora
digamos es mucho más popular y hay mucha
más gente que accede a estos este tipo
de tipos de dispositivo entonces
la mirada de los hackers y la gente que
trata de robar también se posa sobre la
gente que tiene máquinas para más
información
rcn punto se ha luis laborda tú nos
hablas de la extensión de los servicios
de salud virtuales en canadá sí señora
se habla frecuentemente de la salud en
canadá y en quebec también en particular
de los problemas que está esta área
enfrenta entre otras razones por una
carencia de profesionales de la salud y
por el envejecimiento de la población
son dos realidades que vive canadá desde
hace tiempo y una de las propuestas que
ha surgido desde los propios integrantes
del área de la salud es expandir los
servicios de telerrealidad de
telerrealidad perdón de tele salud se
puede decir hacer posible la atención
entre el médico y el paciente a partir
del uso de las nuevas tecnologías
diversos colegios profesionales y
organizaciones que representan a médicos
han dicho que esto es posible que existe
ya la tecnología para llevarla a la
práctica pero claro hay un pequeño
problema que yo lo reflejó ahí en el
artículo que es que como todos sabemos
el ejercicio de la salud tanto en lo que
hace a médicos como enfermeras y a otras
actividades que participan del área es
que estos están regidos por colegios
es que han tomado y lo digo con total
este
me hago cargo de lo que digo en todo
caso que han tomado la actividad bajo su
órbita de influencia y decisión va a
decidir en términos castizos estos
colegios no permiten que otros vengan y
se metan en su campo de acción y el
proyecto en cuestión lo principal que
reclama este proyecto en cuestión es que
la salud sea una cuestión nacional que
no reconozca fronteras entre las
provincias algo que no creo que sea del
agrado de los colegios colegios no sólo
desde el colegio de médicos de acá sino
de todas las provincias ningún cada uno
pues tiene su control del khyber que va
a ver yo quiero de este que realmente la
tele salud o la salud a distancia o la
salud virtual como decías vos qué es lo
que dice también el artículo puede hacer
una realidad aquí en canadá y sobre todo
a corto plazo como pretenden las
autoridades hay un proyecto piloto si no
me equivoco también desde el 6 un
artículo sobre esto hace un par de meses
atrás
el hospital judío de montreal
tiene un proyecto para gente de edad que
tiene problemas desplazamiento para
justamente evitarle la necesidad de
salir con la nieve y todo para poder
hacer este tipo de consultas que por ahí
la gente
mayor tiene como más reflejos
me duele algo preguntó al médico
entonces tienen que desplazarse y para
ese tipo de cosas hay un proyecto piloto
pero esto ya va mucho más allá de un
proyecto piloto y yo alguna vez es un
artículo hace un tiempo atrás también
sobre la gente que no los médicos en
provincias que no alcanzan a vivir con
lo que ganan entonces tratan de trabajar
en otras provincias pero no los dejan
porque los colegios profesionales y la
legislación provincial le impide poder
trabajar entonces tiene que pagar
licencia en las dos ciudades que en
realidad se hace increíble muy simple yo
por mi parte los invito a escuchar este
programa especial que hicimos el día
ayer jueves de sobre el día mundial de
la radio este programa fue que en
colaboración con tres radios asociadas
de radio canadá internacional fue suiza
info radio rumanía internacional y radio
praga internacional puede ser fue un
encuentro muy simpático muy
se enteró solíamos solíamos en otras
épocas cuando estábamos en la onda corta
hacer programas en colaboración con las
otras radios asociadas y bueno para mí
fue un gran placer pues poder compartir
estos momentos con colegas de esas
radios y bueno todavía nos queda un
minuto leonardo si no no preguntaba hay
algunas acciones que sigue todavía en
onda corta
radio rumanía y radio praga siguen en la
onda corta pero swissinfo desde hace
unos 20 años que está solo en el portal
dineral porque perfecto sí bueno y eso
fue todo por este programa de hoy
viernes 14 de febrero de 2020 en vivo y
en directo feliz
y claro nosotros nos pusimos acá pues a
tono con el día estos 20 días sin cerca
sarcasmo que lindo montreal en envión
jajaja bueno nos acompañaron en estudio
pues se leonardo gimeno luis laborda y
en el estudio también estuvieron marie
christine doran ricardo peñafiel y bueno
me despido simplemente diciéndoles hasta
la próxima
[Música]
ah